on this episode I talk about music
important observations and will ads
become too expensive on social media for
small businesses you ask questions and I
answer them
[Music]
this is the askgaryvee show
[Music]
what's up everybody this is gary
vay-ner-chuk and this is episode 82 of
the ask gary vee show all right back in
the saddle
81 after cut Steve didn't come in she
seems like it what did you get all weird
oh I didn't want to keep in on the show
before let's get in here all right I
mean I've every but you've been on the
show before back in the main saddle 81
yesterday in my office was fun people
got to see some different schwag in the
background ask about the Rangers fandom
hardcore Rangers fan from 92 to 94 but
then they won the Cup and once my team's
win I'm out so when the Jets win the
Super Bowl this year two things will
happen I will finally shave my beard and
two I will no longer be a Jets fan let's
get in to the show mark asks well social
media marketing become too expensive for
a new startup to compete with larger
companies for add spots
mark the answers absolutely I mean
that's the whole point that's the whole
point of everything I talked about which
is jump into new places when the grass
is greener ahead of the market to create
the arbitrage when it's under price
compared to the market
Allah email marketing for Wine Library
in 96 and 97 nobody else was doing it I
was asking for it
my conversions were better more people
came the conversion rates went down it
became more expensive and harder to get
people into the email funnel that became
the expense Google AdWords on the word
wine for five ten cents a hell of a lot
better than owning it for two bucks
right
of course it will get more expensive
we're seeing it on Facebook now Facebook
ads to get into the feed that are more
expensive than they were 12 18 24 months
ago even when I started this show and
told you to do dark posts it's gotten
more expensive since then so the answer
and the question and the debate and the
opportunity all lie in the same place
which is what are you doing about
Instagram and snapchat and meerkat and
periscope and all these new things are
you moving there when the audience is
not as big the returns are not as big in
the short term my overall plan is to go
to those places hold my breath for three
or four or five or six or seven months
when it's not as valuable but be there
when it does become more valuable and
then ride that way for 1224 months
before those platforms become and add
their ad
product instagrams app product is still
not mature yet so the organic reach for
the people that jumped on three four or
five years ago because at five years
were different feels like it is now the
nine for Instagram feels right right or
2010 try remember anyway you know but if
you can't look you know you know [ __ ]
Jerry right and like other people that
nature they've won they moved quickly
they've got the biggest audience they
can command enormous dollars so I think
the answer is yes
depending on your budgets it becomes
more price prohibitive what a small
start-up or small business has this time
versus a big brands of money right so
are you willing to work 7:00 p.m. to
3:00 in the morning to get the
disproportion arbitrage of new platforms
to over index before money becomes the
variable I hate when small businesses
are like oh that's it we don't have
money to compete with the big guys what
you have is speed and time what I mean
by that is they have time to but people
that work in corporate America don't
want to stay up to four o'clock in the
morning that often and even if they do
they want to move within the system of
corporate America and they cannot do the
same things you can do it's not that
same entrepreneurial nimble system by
the time they even understand what
snapchat Instagram periscope meerkat are
it takes two years for it to get
approved and in that time you're
executing and so the answer is yes but
that's not a bad thing it only speaks
more to my overall philosophy of jumping
into these new platforms extracting the
value before the add product becomes
mature and then using the add product
Facebook dark posts while everybody else
is waiting now in 2016 17 18 when
Facebook dark posts unpublished posts
the ad product become the mainstream
that's when it becomes prohibitive for
you but you're on to the next one Destin
asks the business I'm in brings a lot of
rejection from family and peers what are
some ways you build confidence when
rejected Destin
which is not Dustin and is not destiny
Destin without a Y or definitely without
a Y you know it's funny when the
question was asked by India one thing
first and foremost you want to make sure
the way to build confidence is to be
confident with yourself I want to make
sure first and foremost that you're not
selling something skeezy right like if
ever
bunny doesn't have confidence around you
maybe you're selling something that is
not the right thing so first and
foremost are you selling the right thing
or are you in Ponzi scheme world you
know are you in $300 eBook world are you
in full-of-shit world if you're not in
full of [ __ ] world take you for somebody
who hasn't been in full of [ __ ] world
his whole career but has done things
that people didn't believe in e-commerce
being number one Wine Library TV being
number two
and then really a social media agency
number three believe it or not I know
nine people still debated this was a
stupid idea I think that um you know if
this is a tough one for me to answer
because the truth is I don't give a crap
what anybody else says as a matter of
fact I'm wired a little bit backwards
I prefer that everybody thinks I'm wrong
I feed off of that negativity and I turn
it into positivity right like I
literally actually prefer it's why I
like bad sports teams it's what it's
interesting we got to active actually
this worked out perfectly the reason I
really would not want to root for the
Yankees anymore I love being a Yankees
fan in the 80s because they stunk the
Mets were the team of the 80s when I was
a kid I loved the climb then they became
the establishment and I pushed against
it it's my overall thing right I'm I'm a
very basic character like I like coming
from the slums
I like being underestimated and the
second I become the establishment aka
the wine world it becomes less
interesting advertising is becoming less
interesting because I'm starting to be
proven to be right and it's just not as
fun like I want the push back so you and
I are wired differently if you're asking
this question my question is like how do
I stay underdog for longer you know and
so I feed off of the negativity I feed
off of like you're not right you're not
right you're not right you're not right
I don't agree I don't agree I don't
agree that's not the way it's always
been done so I might not be the right
person to answer this because it's
always been in me in me is the underdog
in me is the scrapping up in me is that
I'm gonna prove you wrong sucker
William asks I'm growing a millennial
own branding agency here in New Jersey
what are key factors we should be
looking for when hiring other millenials
as we quickly scale well great picture
is a good time to stop
especially for everybody listening so
stop your treadmill pull over on the
side of the road I need more Instagram
picture questions I need more Instagram
picture questions tag askgaryvee or
askgaryvee show
on your Instagram just like this
question so obviously if you're
listening go and watch the show too so I
can show you what I mean but obviously
if you're watching you know exactly what
I mean I'm gonna say one more time
you the audience you the vaynernation oh
go I need a wristband Steve uh you the
vaynernation uh are the oxygen that
allows this show to happen the more you
guys check out or take it for granted or
get into a rut because I wasn't on for
two weeks
the more likely I will stop at episode
94 so like I really really need your
help here to continue the momentum so if
you like this show at all and if you're
shy or not shy either way I basically
need an Instagram photo with a question
here's a link to how you ask the
question and let's move on will I think
building a millennial agency I always
talk about that fat dude that built
Backstreet Boys and NSYNC right he
wasn't a 13 year old girl he just knew
how to market the 13 year old girls I
especially with the gray hairs then some
in the beard which is weird I am NOT a
millennial I know how to market to
Millennials better than all of my
Millennials combined okay so I would say
first things first what do you think in
I papa first things first I would say is
you don't have to and this is a huge
mistake that most people make you don't
necessarily hire millenials to market to
Millennials just cuz you're 24 doesn't
mean you know how to sell [ __ ] to a 24
year old so first and foremost what you
should be thinking about in hiring
people is do people actually know how to
market to the age group the reason I
mentioned that 50-year old fat white
dude is he understood twelve-year-old
girls in pop music better than anyone
just like this 39 year old old dude
understands the behavior of 13 to 23
year olds better than most people so
first what you should be looking for is
can they talk the game to the actual
audience
not necessarily are they the demo of the
actual audience
Shawn asks what's the single most
important observation you've ever made
in your life Shawn I think the biggest
observation I ever made in my life was I
needed to really trust my intuition over
what I was being sold by anybody from my
parents to my teachers to the television
I just you know always talked about
betting on your strengths you know for
me and you know maybe most people are
different like everyone's different but
for me you're asking me the askgaryvee
show that's you know I we called it that
for me it was just somewhere in my early
teens it was just obvious to me that I
was right and I know that's obnoxious
thing to say but my happiness and
success always followed me going down
the path that seemed obvious to me yet I
was confused why everybody else wasn't
it wasn't besides my mom it wasn't so
obvious to and so I that's what I would
say let's say that's uh that's my answer
biggest observation was I was right
don't be scared of what that meant have
the confidence to follow through with
that don't hedge don't respect other
people's points of view have the
humility that has been such an important
balance to the gift of the intuition but
never waver never waver
Clayton asks how do you retain and
increase followers after taking over
social media from a company who bought
their initial fans clean is a great
question I think is a good one at this
point and the maturity of social
networking people realize buying fans on
any platform has absolutely no value
eventually get exposed for being the
scum bucket that you are and so I would
say that um the other thing there's two
different ways to buy fans right like
buying ads on Facebook and Twitter and
Instagram to them if people are
interested to follow is a smart move
just buying like you know going on eBay
and buying 5000 BOTS makes no sense
the funny thing is the answer to your
question is the same way you would if it
was zero whether you have zero followers
for a new wristband brand or you're a
coffee company that they bought a fats
and fans on eBay to try to make it seem
like there were somebody your move the
next day is the exact same which is
let's start from the beginning and try
to make it work so what you're looking
for is engaged fans converting fans
people that will buy your book your wine
will watch your show will pass it on
like and what you need to do for them is
you need to provide them value and so
providing value is the whole game
whether that's listening on Twitter and
engaging whether that's putting out
great content whether that's sweepstakes
entertainment information whatever it is
you need to provide value you need to
put out good content you need to listen
you talk great you need to listen great
you operate in to listen great you to
talk great you need to listen great and
if you're meerkat clicking show is good
you win and if your meerkat cooking show
is [ __ ] you lose it's not really
complicated this stuff is quite basic
you need to put out good stuff and the
question is what is good stuff good
stuff is different to everybody you know
like like Steve named three good music
things musicians bands name three give
me three music things that are good go
sounds good no no yeah things that you
listen to what are three things that you
want to listen to you were willing to
give your twenty minutes that is very
valuable and I will sit down and listen
to these six songs name three acts of
flexpa villian good good good I have no
[ __ ] idea who any of those three
people are stuff on go to him and I know
there's a light but figure it out good
stuff on your turn name three good music
things there you go right great
India I don't care don't blank you know
music go but just figure out what just
happened three lovely people that are
into very different things they would
Steve what do you think about Kanye um I
think he's kind of a jackass but I
thought - it's good stuff on you are
stuff on you are overall thoughts on the
Beach Boys
I'll give you someone I listen to the
music there you go
India what are your thoughts on Lionel
Richie one of my favorites good me and
II agree so bottom line is it's quite
simple right what is quality is 100%
subjective there were plenty of people
in Hollywood 20 years ago that said this
reality TV stuff will never work it's
not produced well it's not good it's not
interesting there's a million people to
think the Kardashians suck there's a
million people that think they're great
there's tens of thousands to think I'm
great there's tens of thousands that
just don't realize I'm great yet I mean
the bottom line is it's all very very
simple quality content is subjective
what is not subjective is what happens
next
aka you may sit and say I'm putting out
great content but after four and a half
years of 13 people are subscribed and
paying attention you just might not be
that good you might not be good at the
content you might not be good at getting
the content out there it's a mix of the
two I'm a byproduct of the mix of the
two I'm good enough to put out content
that people like but I'm also good
enough getting it out there and using
the marketing to bring it awareness and
both matter both matter but that's
really it right like that's really it
like whether you have a billion fake
fans or zero fans aren't you in the same
place zero fans yes you are and thus it
it's like me if I decided to start doing
Wine content again right if I decided to
do that you know I have to start kind of
over like like of course I have my base
people that used to watch the show and
things of that nature but if it's not
good if episode 1,001 of Wine Library TV
is just a disaster show there's a very
unlikely chance that it will be
successful so the quality the content
really really matters and then all the
other growth hacking marketing
strategies all the stuff we talked about
those think of support systems to give
that stuff a better chance to succeed
cool question of the day what are your
three favorite music acts of all time
you keep asking questions I'll keep
answering them
you